[Musique]
à
il était
votre truc du samedi soir bonsoir
cette corvée crié en taxi pour faire
partir une ambiance de fou tracker
m'adapterai si bon soir
alors venez que la star du 10e
anniversaire de l'émission et vous
n'avez pas eu la patience d'attendre dix
ans pour revenir fonctionne source
comprend très bien vous avez eu l'appui
jean mi un robot à 3 milliards de
dollars vous ne l'avez pas rater
jeanne en disant est ce que jean-louis
marchera encore jean-mi dirigera canal
dont tu vois ah ouais bah écoutez c'est
tout ce qu'on vous souhaite me
[Applaudissements]
dit à ma fille que c'est pas pour de
vrai maghrébin
et y aller voilà alors
[Applaudissements]
autre carrière invité ce soir celui qui
fait à la fois le jeu du front national
de l'état islamique et de mylène farmer
michel onfray
[Applaudissements]
vous avez reçu la visite du raid ou pour
encore non encore j'attends mais non
pendait ça va venir alors merci en tous
les cas michel doit respecter votre
engagement d'être avec nous ce soir
malgré la bronca médiatique dont vous
êtes l'objet suite à vos récentes
déclarations vous expliquerai ici ce
soir et l'oral fans
[Applaudissements]
orelsan bon choix êtes rappeur rappeur
et normand oui je sais ça fait toujours
bizarre quand on dit ça
un blanc qui fait du rap c'est aussi
étrange qu'un député noir à l'assemblée
nationale en plein 3 après le zapping et
guillon nous diffuserons l'interview de
nathalie bard et la maman du petit
mathis dont on ne sait toujours pas s'il
est mort ou vivant interviews des
programmes et le 14 novembre en raison
des attentats voilà l'émission s'appelle
salut les terriens et le groupe les
crémants de fortune
[Musique]
et maintenant voici tom villa
or comme tu prends l assurance en ce
moment ouais je voulais une musique un
peu plus un bruit viril ouais c'est bien
semaine dernière il m'a mis jordi lie
mais les village people va c'est tous
les fantasmes sexuels de thierry
platteau incroyable série ce soir on a
on a tous le lobby normand sur le
plateau assez raide michel onfray et
orelsan manque que michel drucker est un
camembert et on était au complet
florence vous êtes la seule normande 1
du plateau mais bon comme vous crachez
pas sur un petit calva on va dire vous
êtes nombreux ici
florence foresti c'est la classe c la
patronne alors dans un article sur vous
j'ai lu florence foresti après 15 ans de
carrière et une grossesse elle est de
retour sur scène
à quand j'ai lu ça mon côté féministe
n'a fait qu'un tour non mais sans
déconner c'est complètement débile de
dire après 15 ans de carrière une
grossesse est ce qu'on dira à propos
d'un mec après 15 ans de carrière et
avoir largué sa femme pour une petite
jeune de 20 ans de moins que lui eh ben
il est de retour sur scène et ben non on
ne dirait pas alors florence vous allez
animer l'ailé césar alors vous nous
direz après mais je crois que tout ce
qu'on présentait les césar sont d'accord
pour dire que le meilleur moment eh ben
ça reste le dîner au fouquet's après
3 non mais j'ai pleinement confiance en
michel onfray michel onfray c'est ça
c'est la classe c'est le premier
philosophe qu'on reçoit de la saison à
part frédéric lopez veut dire mais
alors michel onfray on a dit vous vous
étiez islamophobe soutien de marine le
pen est maintenant défenseur de dèche
voilà alors à tous les petits branleurs
qui nous regardent qui sont au lycée qui
dix mois plus tard je veux être
philosophe vous avez vu c'est quand même
beaucoup dans merde donc s'il n'est pas
finir comme lui bosser à l'école
[Applaudissements]
pour votre dernier ouvrage vous avez
collaboré avec mylène farmer alors c'est
vrai qu'à la base on se dit mylène
farmer et michel onfray qui bossent
ensemble
c'est un peu comme christine and the
queen et didier barbelivien il ya un
truc qui déconne et puis en fait elle a
fait les dessins de votre livre alors
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
elle a fait des dessins très joyeux
plein de couleur gris clair gris foncé
gris et noir noir brillant noir mat
c'était très très bien c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai non à coup il ya eu un
bleu foncé alors
orelsan orelsan je le déteste non mais
vraiment parce que ma copine l'adorent
et en fait et vous trouve trop beau et
quand ils vous regardent à la télé elle
a dites vous que vous aviez un petit
côté crade excitant alors je te jure que
c'est vrai moi du coup pour lui faire
plaisir j'ai essayé de me laver pendant
trois jours elle a juste trouvé que
j'avais un côté crade tout court mais ça
alors orelsan pour les personnes qui
connaîtraient pas la base des rappeurs
mais maintenant il est comédien est là
vous jouez dans un programme court sur
canal+ qui s'appelle bloqué à l'origine
le titre c'était de connaître dans un
canapé mais c'était déjà le surnom donné
thierry à vivement dimanche donc tout ça
mesdames et messieurs ma mission ici et
de poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
posez
michel onfray et si vous pensez que que
le fait que vous croyez en rien est un
rapport avec le fait que vous viviez en
normandie
orelsan orelsan en 1998 vous avez été
éboueurs est aujourd'hui votre
producteur de spectacle s'appelle
olivier poubelle
non mais c'est vrai c'est parce que vous
croyez au signe du destin que vous avez
signé avec lui ou pas
florence foresti votre fille vous voit
partir donc travailler quand il fait
nuit et rentre avec plein d'argent le
matin c'est ce que vous faites dans la
vie votre voix
[Applaudissements]
bonne émission merci c'est une ville à
mon stagiaire en 2006 le brussels est
actuellement au théâtre apollo
elle triomphe partout en france bientôt
à bercy elle est au top
c'est françoise
[Applaudissements]
je reçois réussir bonsoir ça alors on
jette ici ce soir pour nous parler de
votre tournée à travers la france deux
bercy les 22 et 23 décembre et de la
sortie du dvd madame foresti vous nous
annoncera également que désormais vous
êtes la maîtresse officielle de
huy de la scène du caesar forfait
[Musique]
alors
nous est la femme la plus drôle de
france une sorte de miss france de
l'humour non mais c'est vrai vous êtes
considéré comme la patronne des filles
humoristes en france la parraine comme
dirait alessandra sublet
en gros c'est votre faute si des
dizaines de gamines ont laissé tomber
leurs études pour monter sur scène et
faire rire avec la pose d'un tampon
c'est de votre faute ah non c'est pas
moi qui guident vers ce genre de papa
elles veulent vous imitez tout
elle vous cite tout comme leur modèle
à part qu'elles sont gaulé comme des
[__]
[Applaudissements]
section tournée dans toute la france
avec madame foresti c'est le fort et
stewards doivent tous -ou son supplice
madonna voit ça reste mon idole oui elle
ça c'est si on vous dit j'adore les
tournées
gt1
j'adore les tournées si j'étais un mec
j'abuse ray du succès j'ai dit ça ouais
l'outaouais
comme vous êtes une maman célèbre vous
retrouvez à manger froid parce qu'on en
province anouk a rien d'ouvert après dix
heures du soir et vous vous dînez avec
votre garde du corps en fait grosse
impression
oui oui c'est vrai j'ai souvent dit que
les hommes il avait les groupies pour
les occuper en tournée nous on n'a pas
les groupies comprenait pas des gigolos
brasse existe pas c'est pas à toi
comment ça n'est pas non mais je n'ai
pas eu le nom wii face cachée connu la
célébrité
garrett
alors 22 23 décembre à bercy sauf que
maintenant ça s'appelle l'accord
hauts-de-seine à rennes pourquoi pas le
telle formule un stadium
je crois que bercy restera un ballon
dira jamais encore war in a hotel tiens
on va voir hugh tout accord arena hôtel
fout de la gueule toi ouais fatima sa
passion on dirait jamais cela c'est
impossible alors flanc c'est ce que la
fréquentation nouveau spectacle a
souffert des attentats du 13 novembre
écoute mes salles sont pleines c'est
l'artiste qui est un peu plus plus
vulnérables
moi j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de mal et
pourtant c'était cinq jours après
cinq jours ou pas je veux dire c'était
extrêmement difficile mais comme le
public était là vraiment il n'y avait
pas d'autre choix que que
il montrait un bel exemple quoi eux
étaient là donc ça lui soit alors une
lueur d'espoir quand même à préciser at
on entendu du 13 novembre
francis lalanne n'a pas composé de
chansons
alors si on peut pas aller à bercy il ya
le dvd le dvd madame forest stick et qui
est sorti on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
comprenez par là en tout cas dans ce
genre de fille tu c'est hyper féminine
très très séduisant tu vois qu'ils sont
capables de dire des trucs dans le temps
si on peut plus [__] un pion en boîte
on se fait draguer
ça c'est amusant parce qu'alors moi je
peux passer un bon moment sans
s'en suivirent le cadre des rangements 1
ah ouais acheter sur moi je peux passer
trois quatre années pénard donc ça
non écoute à son épatante mais il ya des
filles comme ça les grandes séductrices
j'appelle ça tu vois j'en ai plein mon
entourage des filles comme ça des ventes
un peu tu vois des femmes fatales qui
sont capables de débarquer sur leur mec
un soir à l'improviste comme ça avec un
trench et rien de sourdes
moi j'aurais trop peur qu'ils se foutent
de ma gueule
est ce que tu fous
inspecteur gadget
[Musique]
alors vous devez déclarer pour écrire je
dois racler le fond de moi-même et vivre
puisque finalement je m'inspire de ma
vie effectivement pour nourrir vos
spectacles ya eu la naissance de votre
fille ensuite la star étude les quarante
ans alors tout le monde a hâte que vous
faites chez hbo aux 50 ans ouais nous
fassiez un beau spectacle sur
l'ostéoporose
et la ménopause alors à part ça vous
allez animer des césar alors votre
mission est simple empêcher les
téléspectateurs de se suicider devant
leur écran on en est là dès fier quand
vous avez montré des extraits de films
américains se calment et je trouve qu'on
vous voit pas assez au cinéma moi aussi
non
à bonjour moi pourriez faire une
carrière à la de funès vous
croyais appelé il ya plus les
réalisateurs il ya plus quoi mais ce
court pas après aussi eh oui si je me le
jeu décidé que c'est un casse mais je
moi je suis très bien sur scène alors il
ya quelques années vous aviez draguer
sean penn aux césar vous lui aviez fait
la bise c'était il ya trois ans vous
pensez que s'il n'a jamais envoyé de
texto c'est que les timides mois l'année
où il y avait le challenge était
beaucoup plus impressionné par dustin
hoffman dans la salle que vous aimez les
sugar d'allier les quoi les sugar daddy
oui non catégorique sur youporn
c'est comme les
1000 chez un cheval
mais
voilà c'était la place de ce fait on se
retrouve
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir lecteurs sont de retour
sur terre toujours en compagnie de
florence foresti
[Applaudissements]
jo
elle tord asle somme
à l'emploi
vous êtes maman depuis huit ans sans
réduction de peine ferme ferme ouais on
va faire une interview bilan de maman
[Musique]
alors que l'once vous êtes maman depuis
huit ans oui est-ce que vous commencez à
maîtriser le job je crois que je reste
agir
on dit que quand on est parent le plus
douloureux c'est quand on marche sur un
lego pied nul
mais ce que je pense plus douloureux
encore c'est qu'on l'enfant marche sur
un lego l'année parce qu'il pleure
beaucoup plus fort alors on dit qu il
existerait des mamans qui sont toujours
à l'heure à l'école qu'on peut aller
chez le coiffeur qui ont pas de tâche de
deux vomi sur l'épaule vous en
connaissez mais maman parfaite bien sûr
mais il ya pire que la maman qui arrive
toujours à l'heure à l'école il ya celle
qui est en retard mais qui s'en fout à
et celle là je lui en veux tu vois celle
qui sort x et agrafes ça peut arriver
parce que moi ça
alors celle là les fortes et si votre
fille était fan de violetta et ben il
faut lui acheter des écouteurs ces
problèmes
à choisir j'aurais pas préféré avoir un
césar plutôt qu'un enfant
j'ai été césarisé mais voilà c'est ça
revienne c'est bon ça c'est pareil non
mais c'est ce qui paraît qu'il n'y
paraît et des français
entre à césar et à l'horizontale
ressemble au début c'est compressé passé
c'est non mais
c'est ce que ferait aussi quoi et sur
les garçons ongles le dit quoi à bages
et ça sent pas bon
non je vais dire oui que c'était que
qu'ils étaient prêts à tout pour voir
une fille en soutien gorge son nom mais
c'est ça l'a compris a dit pourquoi ils
sont situés dans la télé tout ça elle
voit qu'ils sont complètement faux et
que les fiches dit oui ça ça reste à
tous les âges ils sont fous pour voir
une fille entretient elle sait déjà ce
que c'est un soutien de l'argent bien
sûr du 8 ans quand même à l'antarctique
à te regarde maintenant
quel est votre petit truc de maman quand
votre enfant vous écoute pas utiliser le
chantage sert énormément moi je fais
tout ce qu'il faut pas chantage
culpabilisation cris je suis une mère
juive en fait qu'est-ce que votre fille
vous a fait découvrir sur vous-même et
j'étais juive
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qu'il faut faire un autre enfant
des grands brito non hein
non
non vraiment ça tu vois je ne sais pas
vraiment rigole mme amory bellegarde on
n'a pas eu besoin de l'alcool pour ça
non si j'étais le père je crois que ce
travail parce que je trouve que le père
s'est passé un truc que je sais faire
justement faire rire le goth le voir une
fois par semaine lui donner un petit
bain
l'emmener au restaurant que les pas
passer ces coups là j'étais le père sont
au raid 5 ou 6 au final oui qu'est-ce
qui lé nul sinon l'enfant
est qu'un césar serait pas mal
finalement
[Musique]
voilà
orelsan dreumont soir aux usa
mesdames messieurs auraient 5 celui
qu'on appelle d'eminem d'alençon à alcan
ne sait toujours pas comment il doit le
prendre
alors qu'osram aux apparences vous êtes
rappeur dit contrairement aux apparences
parce que vous êtes blanc pas très
musclé vous ne voulez pas manquer la
france
et vous savez conjuguer les verbes au
présent de l'indicatif
et c'est très bien bravo d'emmener deux
camps ouais votre mère était prof votre
père directeur de collège à vos débuts
dans le rap j'ai préféré dire que votre
mère était en taule dès que votre père
deal et du crack j'imagine
j'ai pas menti non moi même j'étais pas
très crédible quoi qu'il arrive et à
fallait il a fallu jouer cartes sur
table
vous avez fait des études de management
alors je continue ou je suis en train de
[__] en l'air votre carrière non
j'avais fait la dose classe
vous vous êtes fait connaître avec ça
[Musique]
sa
solution d'un mec qui est super vénère
parce que ça mon fils a quitté bon alors
évidemment les gens hurlaient en
entendant ça sous votre grand mère qui a
très bien compris qu'elle et son mari
elle a dit tu vois jean quelques fois tu
m'énerves et j'ai envie de titres
anglais mais c'est juste ce qu'il
raconte
c'était l'histoire d'un mec qu envoyer
un mail ouais ouais donc en fait ouais
la cécilia vraiment je trouve que cote
quand on a besoin d'exprimer des
émotions assez violente c'est mieux de
le faire en chanson que par n'importe
quel autre moyen alors ni [__] ni
soumises de les chiennes de garde ont
moins bien compris clic que votre grand
mère est toujours en procès mouais j'ai
gagné deux procès sur trois est de
rester le premier procès l'appel de
l'annoncé en cassation il faut dire que
ségolène royal vous a fait déprogrammé
des francofolies et le pire c'est que
j'ai soutenu frédéric lefebvre ça y est
soutenu par frédéric lefebvre emmerdant
mais vaut mieux pas tout je veux dire
quoi il y avait beaucoup de girouette un
coup j'étais soutenu à droite après à
gauche après à droite alors elles savent
de tichy ce soir non pas pour un disque
mais pour un film ça s'appelle comment
c'est loin vous l'interprétez avec votre
complice grainge vous l'avez coréalisé
avec christophe offenstein alors le
pitch à caen
aurait les granges galère pour écrire
leur premier album de rap leurs
producteurs la mettre une grosse
pression et leur donne une deadline 24
heures pour sortir une chanson voilà
mais leur légendaire procrastination les
potes envahissant les problèmes de
couple ne vont pas les faire avancer
voilà c'est des mecs qui font de la
musique depuis dix ans et un jour ils se
rendent compte qu'ils ont jamais fini
une seule chanson
c'est terrible ouais c'est un buddy
movie quoi ces deux antihéros de deux
losers vous vous buvez grande je vais
avoir des put enfin bon c'est un on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble
mais l'invité de ce soir guillaume tran
chagrin mois ses grandes oreilles il
s'appelle or elle en fait pour moi rap
c'est ici comme un exercice de maths m6
était mort dans la cité morts sur l'île
de batz mais leur album à la bande avec
un seul traque un seul bras que ces
jeunes qui rêvent de vivre de parfum et
depuis vous avez pas fini un seul
morceau non mais ça prend du temps de
faire un bon morceau cinq ans or elle ne
peut pas aller plus vite que la musique
marek d'autres foutent de ma gueule
grain je vous ai fait cette maquette en
cinq ans et si on vous fait un son pour
demain mais vous n'êtes pas capables
toute façon les mecs mais si on est
capable mais nantes et sa cape annonce
mais sinon mais sinon non si je dis que
sinon oui sa mort c'est impossible on a
du boulot il ya zéro chance consorts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous donnais un seul et unique
conseil les mecs sept meilleurs
abandonné et je serais pas un peu [__]
les ventes on s'aime plus tard zones
érogènes dur mais deux personnes ne
touche jamais ton corps en façade est
une zone érogène les méfaits supporter
un accouchement elle supporte pas une
vanne à nos histoires morte avant
d'avoir démarré odeurs laissez passer
popote jamais rappelée auteurs que j'ai
lâché aux fortes que j'ai claqué
je laisse de mer d'août a cru qu'on
allait percer dans le rap mon gars mais
on n'a rien de spécial mon pote on n'a
rien ok
depuis on attend
mercier la route est longue
comment j'ai faim commencée loin
seb à la bouche même coup
tu peux te connais toi que dans les bus
sont qu'à la place de traîner tu
retombes de son studio s'appelle savais
même pas qu'il y ait des buissons
voilà comment c'est moi
tellement c'est vraiment le fun qu'il
faut aller voir ce complètement décalé
alors bon gros boulot faut le dire parce
que vous êtes à la fois scénariste
réalisateur comédien compositeur c'est
qu'à part en ce noël c'est des charlots
temps j'adore les charlots
personne n'avait fait ça on vous en fait
vous avez pris tous les jobs pour être
nominé dans le plus de catégories
possibles aux césars j'imagine moi je
l'espère n'était pas à l'abri d'avoir un
prix je vais te dire moi ok non tu fais
si tu veux dîner avec moi
du pouvoir
alors vous êtes vous une sorte de héros
pour la génération qui glandent toute la
journée sur un canapé en regardant la
télé ou son smartphone vous allez
convaincre comment ces gens là de sortir
de chez eux pour aller voir votre film
piraté importer les films que j'ai
moi-même
autour de l'accord le pire de tout c'est
que c'est une bonne critique dans
télérama c'est un film d'une sensualité
hilarante moderne et ambre pas fou
actuellement ce que j'aurais dit en
sortie de banc et c'est bien normal
c'est vrai qu'il ya unité de lieu unité
de temps et unité d'inaction
j'ai bien regardé comment luc besson
faisait ses films et j'ai fait le
contraire
[Musique]
michel onfray re bonsoir
alors michel
traiter d'islamophobe quand vous
dénonciez les versets belliqueux du
coran
traiter d'islamophobe quand vous vous
opposez aux frappes sur l' état
islamique
vous êtes au centre d'une bronca
médiatique très violente et ici ce soir
pour vous expliquer nous expliquer notre
désintox de ce soir c'est vous
[Musique]
on ferait accuse la france chirac à
bombarder l'afghanistan
sarkozy a bombardé la libye hollande a
bombardé l'irak et la syrie bref la
france n'arrête pas de bombarder les
musulmans
massacrent les populations arabes les
populations musulmanes nous menons en
france une politique islamophobe selon
michel onfray quand des shs assassines
des innocents à paris c'est donc une
opération de représailles résultat des
ch a récupéré des extraits d'interviews
de monfreid pour les utiliser dans ses
clips de propagande en revanche en
france les propos de michel onfray font
scandale je crois que il faut en finir
avec
l'ethnocentrisme de la mauvaise
conscience
l'occident doit se défaire une fois pour
toutes de la croyance mégalomaniaque que
c'est lui en toute circonstance qui mène
le bal là où ça se complique c'est que
onfray accuse la france d'être
islamophobe
alors que lui même est extrêmement
critique contre l'islam et si vous lisez
le coran si vous regardez la vie du
prophète si vous lisez les a dit qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans la logique
républicaine on est dans l'antisémitisme
on est dans la haine de l'étranger on ne
naît pas dans une logique pacifiste
fonds défend la peine de mort on défend
l'égorgement sa fidèle et c'est qu'il
faut lire quand on ferait parle de
l'islam il ne fait pas dans la nuance il
a l'air de croire que tous les musulmans
du monde ont une lecture intégristes du
coran comme s'il n'y avait pas un islam
modéré comme s'il n'y avait pas de
musulmans qui défendent la laïcité la
réalité est un peu plus complexe l'islam
et je le répète encore pour ceux qui
ignorent encore que le coran dit qui tue
une seule personne à tuer l'humanité
tout entière onfray accuse les
etats-unis de l'onu
l'islam parce qu'ils vont chasser saddam
hussein du pouvoir le problème c'est que
saddam hussein était un dictateur laïque
comme bachar el-assad aujourd'hui et
quand la france à renverser kadhafi ce
n'était pas pour attaquer les musulmans
mais officiellement pour défendre les
droits de l'homme et la démocratie dans
le cadre des printemps arabes la france
la grande bretagne et l'europe seront
toujours aux côtés du peuple libyen sauf
que pour michel onfray tout ça c'est de
l'hypocrisie
la preuve on fait la guerre à des shows
alors on s'entend très bien avec
l'arabie saoudite qui bafoue les droits
de l'homme de la même manière alors que
faire ben notre philosophe n'est pas
très optimiste selon lui une guerre de
civilisation s'est engagée entre
l'occident et l'islam et son pronostic
nous ne nous est pas favorable
quand une civilisation s'effondre et
qu'à proximité une hotte est en train de
se proposer l'oumma la communauté
universelle avec des individus qui sont
prêts à mourir à se faire sauter avec
des ceintures d'explosifs en disant
qu'on croit notre civilisation on croit
notre culture les vrais civilisation se
constitue avec les gens qui peuvent
mourir qui veulent mourir qui font la
défense de la guerre mais y'a pas un
occidental qui est prêt à mourir pour
ses idées alors évidemment si l'occident
est foutu à quoi bon se battre pour
défendre nos valeurs mais saint michel
c'est pas du pacifisme c'est du
défaitisme
voilà c'était désintox signé blaco mise
en image de julien grappes michel
souhaité réagir sur le sur ce que vous
venez de voir oui écouter chaque chaque
plan me concernant doit durer deux
secondes si vous pensez qu'en deux
secondes on peut dire quelque chose
d'intelligent mais en revanche on peut
dire quelque chose de fatal pour celui
qui a parlé ans qu'on fasse la grâce
d'imaginer qu'il faut plusieurs phrases
pour développer c'est ce qu'on va faire
ce soir et voilà mais tu dire
qu'effectivement prélevant de phrases
sorties comme ça complètement de leur
contexte on va me faire dire tout et le
contraire de tout alors on va reprendre
les choses au début le 10 septembre
dernier dans le figaro au sujet de la
réticence de certains français à
accueillir les migrants vous déclarez je
n'y vois rien d'obscène ni de xénophobe
vous dit comprendre dans ce papier le
paysan faillite où le chômeur longue
durée vite c'est à ce peuple que par le
marine le pen je lui en veux - à elle
qu'à ceux qui la rendent possible donc
libération vous accuse d'être un
auxiliaire du du lepénisme et les medias
souviennent de vos déclarations sur le
coran sur l'islam et vous déclare
islamophobe donc ça c'est le moment où
vous êtes considéré comme le peniste et
islamophobe même époque suite à une
interview sur lci
on vous traite d'islamo fils en effet
vous dites nous devrions nous la france
6,6 de bombarder les populations
musulmanes sur la totalité de la planète
est d'ailleurs dahesh vous utilise dans
ses vidéos vous réagissez comme ans à sa
main avant j'étais à bordeaux chose une
conférence je découvre une quinzaine de
messages sur mon portable et jeu 10
qu'est ce qui est dit je veux savoir un
petit peu ce qu'ils aiment précisé
bandits pour pouvoir avoir un jugement
ensuite je me dis est ce qu on me fait
dire quelque chose ou est ce que je dis
quelque chose véritablement toujours
dans la logique du du prélèvement
évidemment on peut prendre cet extrait
là et ça veut dire que quiconque dira
que la solution n'est pas un militaire
et guerrière mais pacifiques et
diplomatiques passera pour un ami de
neige est ce qu'on peut penser comme ça
moi je crois pas je retire parce que
j'ai dit je pense effectivement que on a
toujours besoin de 50 ans pour estimer
que les guerres qui ont été faites
n'aurait pas dû être fait aujourd'hui on
embrasse les enfants y en a plus mais
les poilus s'embrasser sous l'arc de
triomphe aujourd'hui les anciens nazis
ce s'embrassent avec les canadiens et
les américains au mémorial pour la paix
accord parce que tout le monde se
réconcilie les anciens de la guerre
d'algérie se réconcilient et c est jeudi
combien de morts faudra-t-il pour que
nous puissions arriver à nous
réconcilier avec des gens avec lesquels
il faudra se réconcilier puisque je suis
sur une analyse camusienne camus disait
au moment de la guerre d'algérie faut
faire la guerre aux gens sachant qu'il
faudra faire la paix un jour où alors on
part pour une guerre de 100 ans alors le
13 novembre après les attentats de paris
vous twittez droite et gauche qui ont
internationalement semer la guerre
contre l'islam politique
récolte nationalement la guerre de
l'islam politique alors vous dites islam
politique vous ne dites pas djihadisme
terrorisme islamisme et islam politique
oui parce qu'il ya plusieurs façons
d'être musulman moi j'ai jamais mis tous
les musulmans dans le même sac ça me
paraît évident je les ai toujours dit
j'ai dit il ya dans le coran des
sourates dangereuse et des sourates qui
ne le sont pas je les lui le coran donc
il faudrait que l'islam se détermine en
disant nous prélevons dans le coran ce
qui nous permet un islam républicain
compatible avec les valeurs qui sont
celles de liberté égalité fraternité à
quoi s'ajoutent laïcité féminisme jeudi
je dis simplement ça je n'ai jamais dit
que tous les musulmans étaient des
terroristes alors vous dites il faut
arrêter de faire la politique coloniale
qui est la nôtre sous prétexte que ça
serait les droits de l'homme qu'il
animerait il c'est vrai que ce droit
d'ingérence au service des droits de
l'homme en fait c'est du colonialisme
oui écouté par exemple le gia a mis en
terriblement l'algérie pendant des
années ouais les estimations donnent
cinq cent mille morts cinq cent mille
morts pourquoi est-ce que la france
n'est pas intervenue militairement
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas
intervenu là vous dites tout a commencé
avec george bush qui a envahi l'irak en
2003 il est quand même eu le 11
septembre avant quand même 18 1990 avant
ouais de 1990 aux attentats du 13
novembre
la france faisant partie des coalitions
occidentales a bombardé un certain
nombre de pays et a fait un certain
nombre de morts savez combien
4 millions alors quatre millions de
morts quatre millions de morts muscles
explique qu' un châtelain des morts 90
dans tous ces pays libye afghanistan
irak syrie et ses quatre millions de
morts musulmans qui comptent pour rien
art puise la france ne peut pas être le
gendarme du monde
surtout qu'en général les gendarmes
savaient des usa et dans le point du 19
novembre on vous déclarez la france doit
cesser sa politique islamophobe
congrès oui bombardé des pays qu'ils
sont innocents du terrorisme en plus
parce que c'est avec l'irak la libye
l'afghanistan mali on n'a jamais en
france de gens de ces pays là qui
venaient poser des bombes dans le métro
par exemple ils étaient si peu dangereux
pour nous la france que nous avons
accueilli bachar el-assad sur les
champs-elysées kad merad a dit un poème
à bachar el assad ce jour là à quoi on
ajoute l'invitation de kadhafi en france
ce n'est pas un ennemi à l'époque à quoi
on ajoute tous les contrats nucléaires
qui ont été signés avec l'irak de saddam
hussein avant 1990 ça se passait très
bien et saddam hussein on le sait a
financé les campagnes présidentielles de
tel ou tel des syriens qui est devenu
président de la république par la suite
donc il ya juste un moment donné où il
faut se dire mais qu'est ce que c'est
que cette politique qui se moquaient
absolument des droits de l'homme à
l'époque et qui qui a considéré que ces
gens là était fréquentable alors
qu'aujourd'hui on voudrait ne pas ne ne
pas fredonner pas fréquenter des
individus qui ont comment les gens
comment les français on leur a expliqué
à yagg même pas trois semaines que
poutine c'était le grand satan voulait
pas lui vendre le bateau ça me batte au
mistral
aujourd'hui on obligeait discuté avec
lui on nous a dit poutine poutine c'est
un méchant man on nous dit c'est ouais
mais ça rend dans quinze jours oui mais
les journées des revenus fréquentable
mais les gens ne sont pas éduqués tu
région ne sont pas éduqués ils écoutent
le journal de 20 heures il écoute france
inter release libération lisent le monde
et on leur sort exactement la même chose
et sur internet et un gros bruit boulga
tous ces gens d'un seul qu'on leur dise
ne cherchez pas c'est simple l'axé du
bien l'axé du mal nous on est dans l'axé
du bien eux ils sont dans l'axé du mal
remarquer michel dans toutes les guerres
les peuples ont été victimes de la
propagande d'état c'est pourquoi je
pense que avant de commencer à faire la
guerre je ne suis pas opposé à la guerre
je dis simplement que ce serait ridicule
d'être un pacifiste absolue en disant
jamais la guerre j'ai découvert ce matin
que 53% des allemands étaient opposés à
cette guerre est ce que les allemands
font le jeu de dèche j'ai découvert que
angela merkel disait que le problème ne
se règlerait pas de manière militaire
mais de manière diplomatique je ne dis
que ça je pense effectivement qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une solution qui ne sont pas
la guerre qu'on n'a pas essayé qui sont
des solutions de diplomatie qui sont des
solutions où effectivement la france
pourrait redevenir gaullienne c'est à
dire la france des lumières bien après
les attentats de paris
d'affaires un communiqué où ils disent
des centaines dit delattre dans une fête
de la perversité dont on voit bien là
le choc des civilisations hélas dire
depuis des années moi je dis qu'une
thing tonnes à raison quelqu'un qui a
pensé la question du choc d'utilisation
c'est pas quelqu'un qui a dit qu'il
fallait faire la guerre c'est quelqu'un
qui a dit que les civilisations était
constituée sur une spiritualité qui elle
même était constituée sur des religions
je suis athée je dis depuis un salon
temps je les écris j'ai fait un livre
pour pour le dire très précisément mais
je suis un judéo-chrétien lattes et que
je suis ce qu'il est le produit d'une
situation qui est judéo chrétienne c'est
ma civilisation et je défends c'est à la
demande oui c'est la nôtre tous autour
de cette table autour d'eux sur ce
plateau et puis on a en face des gens
qui nous dit bah non pas nous vous dites
que ces gens-là dahesh disons l'état
islamique dispose d'une vision
l'histoire que nous n'avons plus c'est
vrai qu'ils ont un but
les français vous dites ils ont une
ferveur sans objet c'est vrai c'est vrai
que quand on voit les marches blanches
les slogans infantilisant les bougies
sur les fenêtres des fleurs sur les
trottoirs les poèmes sur les murs des
drapeaux en berne et minute de silence
on se dit mais qu'est né ce peuple
finalement qui est juste capable d'
émotion s qui n'a pas déjà perdu la
guerre un peuple qui réagit en pleurant
ou grands prions ou en priant le pire
c'est plein effort pareil talent en
anglais wes d'abord et ensuite on nous
dit la solution c'est la prière terrible
pour l'année que je suis est perdus
c'est une horreur évidemment c'est
facile la compassion on vous a reproché
d'ailleurs dans votre tweet du 13
novembre
vous dites finalement on a semé non et
on récolte ont récolté les gens disent
mais on ferait il aurait pu avoir quand
même un petit peu de compassion pour les
victimes et bien la compassion je lui ai
simplement je trouve que ça s'affiche
pas j'aurais pu faire une photo d'une
bougie et j'avais 4000 retweete en
disant bravo etc j'aurais pu mettre du
bleu blanc rouge sur le visage à me
faire à celle fille en disant voilà
j'aurais pu dire je suis jean moulin
parce que j'ai pris un café à la
terrasse d'un café n'est pas fait je ne
juge pas je dis les gens au droit la
bougie londres offre à la fleur l ombre
aux poèmes ils ont droit à tout ça mais
le philosophe a le droit de penser aussi
faire son boulot alors vous avez déclaré
l'occident est finie parce qu'on fasse
de nous il ya la communauté de l'oumma
car l'ensemble des musulmans qui sont
prêts à mourir pour leur foi alors est
ce que le fait d'être prêts à mourir
pour une cause fait de vous le gagnant à
la sortie non pas du tout je dis juste
que si on regarde l'histoire plein de
gens qui vont nous regarder ce soir et
des pas mal de gens ici ont pu prendre
des vacances en egypte et voir les
pyramides à rome et voir le forum à
athènes et voir le parthénon donc
constaté voir stone age ou etc ou aller
chez les incas constater que les
civilisations sont mortelles bien sûr
que les civilisations ont eu lieu et
puis qu elles ont disparu la nôtre est
bien il échapperait à ça on aura une
espèce d'extra territorialité le
judéo-christianisme ce serait pour
toujours et ce serait ça échapperait à
ce qui a concerné les civilisations
depuis le début de l'humanité hélas non
et je vois la communauté planétaire de
luma qui elle est en pleine forme parce
que justement au sens de nietzsche
grande santé parce qu'elle dispose de
soldats prêts à mourir et que nous n'y a
pas un seul type qui est prêt à mourir
pour son iphone
voilà
c'est une année de recul on se retrouve
bien la pub avec le zapping guillon et
ne paie rien du samedi 20 heures ce soir
nathalie paraître dit à maman du petit
matin
notons celle du jour parmi les morts
figure
déprogrammé
j'attends ce moment à cologne
honda a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir nigeria bonsoir les terriens
nous sommes de retour sur terre toujours
en compagnie de plomb ce vol
[Applaudissements]
michaud
et orelsan
le 14 novembre dernier
nous devions diffusé l'interview de
nathalie bard est la maman du petit
mathis mais les attentats nous en ont
évidemment empêché je vous propose de la
voir ce soir après le zapping et guillon
on passe au zapping
c'était le zapping jusqu'ici tout allait
bien voici stéphane guillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on commence par le cri d'alarmé de
valérie pécresse lancé lors d'un meeting
à drancy l'un des terroristes filmé dans
le métro at elle dit était en train de
frauder cela commence par là oui si
cette semaine votre enfant à frauder
dans le métro s'il a sauté par dessus un
portillon n'hésitez pas une seconde
contacter le numéro vert mis en place
par le gouvernement
stop djihadisme au 0 800 00 56 96 on
commence par sauter un portillon puis 1
on saute tout court
je sais bien que de ce terrible le
cliché pris le 5 décembre 80 jacques
chirac sautant à portillon
depuis l'ancien président a fini en
martyr reclus quai voltaire sous la
surveillance de bernadette et d'un
bichon maltais
[Musique]
patrick balkany furieux que sa ville de
levallois soit jumelé avec molenbeek
plaque tournante du djihadisme mais non
non c'est fait exprès entre villes
jumelées vous avez des échanges des
partenariats pour les apprentis
djihadistes de molenbeek faire un stage
chez les balkany et le top sales à
brahim sami omar vous partez dix jours à
le bâlois argent sale blanchiment
fausses factures détournement de fonds
publics patrick va tous vous apprendre
c'est le meilleur de sa profession
[Applaudissements]
conséquence des attentats le fabricant
de jouets toy'r'us retire les armes en
plastique de ses magasins en revanche
barbie dèche est toujours en vente un
modèle bien moins cher que barbie
princesse ou barbie top model ben oui
barbie dèche n'ayant pas le droit de
sortir pas besoin d'acheter le cheval la
voiture ou le carrosse et comme elle est
toujours en burqa pas de garde-robe pas
de maquillage pack bijoux seul
accessoire à sécateurs scies barbie
dèche manque de respect hakem le barbu
et bien il peut lui couper la main
si elle recommence syriens commencent il
peut lui couper la viande en mauricie et
si barbie dèche se rebelle
si elle trompe qu'est le barbu est bien
dit il encore
et bourg c'est ma vie pour l'achat de
deux babic daage cette semaine l'état
islamique vous offre un mug michel
onfray
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une fatwa c'est en moi et mes collègues
j'interviendrai merci signalons aussi
une barbie zahia et oui et oui
l'ancienne call girl zahia a souhaité
poser en marianne en hommage aux
victimes non non non ça s'appelle pas un
hommage c'est un peu dommage
un dommage collatéral
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre conséquence des attentats la
popularité de françois hollande en
hausse
oui de sept points après charlie pareil
il avait grimpé dans sa tête ça doit
être compliqué les seuls moments où tu
prend des points c'est quand il ya un
drame c'est un coup à devenir addict un
président président et un colis suspect
est ce un hasard [__] manuel rester
sur le coup des victimes pas encore
président et évacué la zone ah merde ils
sont obligés
ils peuvent pas laisser quelques
personnes autour un écolier une femme
enceinte le chômage a encore augmenté
faut que je me refasse
[Musique]
l'elysée a diffusé sur son compte
twitter les félicitations de steven
spielberg à françois hollande doit
steven spielberg qui félicite hollande
le guardian qui le comparent à john
wayne est-ce qu'on devrait pas aussi lui
donner un césar d'honneur oui à ou un
prix spécial à cannes remis par
dominique besnehard
battant françois hollande c'est un chef
de guerre extraordinaire à c'est un
mélange de llauro de john wells et
l'inspecteur harry quand il dit la
france ne laissera pas faire notre
réponse sera impitoyable a des frissons
dans le dos aux pratiques aouina mais
tout d'un coup c'est charles bronson
dans le justicier 1 c'est comme denis
halliday quand ils disent ils n'étaient
pas sans heurt direct combattent da s
allumer le feu chez en face les barbus
sont impressionnés attaque johnny johnny
a de quoi voir les ce crunch
on termine cette chronique qui avec un
coup de chapeau à notre invité michel
onfray qui grâce à un seul tweet est
devenue dans la nuit du 13 au 14
novembre une star internationale
fabrice luchini qui affectionne
particulièrement la philosophie a
souhaité tout comme moi saluer
l'ascension fulgurante de michel onfray
niche l onf reste ardèche là c'est
énorme t'imagines le gars d'origine
modeste naissance à caen fils d'ouvrier
agricole en 75 il travaille dans une
fromagerie l'enchaînent les petits
boulots il galère pas mal et peu à peu
il s'en sort pigiste à ouest-france prof
de philo ça commence à sourire le gars
est brillant beau parleur on l'invite
chez ruquier quelques succès de
librairie l'art de jouir cosmos
politique du rebelle l'immense politique
urbaine
est là
las uniquement vide et jenny vendredi 13
novembre paris est en feu 130 morts les
mômes fusillé en terrasses font encore
tiède aux vrais tweets en pleine nuit la
philosophique en quartzite oui tu
réfléchis après mon vrai balance la cure
est un truc du style fallait pas les
emmerder on n'a que ce qu'on mérite qui
sème le vent récolte la tempête
et là tout d'un coup c'est la gloire des
shs le met dans un clip le prof de
campath à l'international on ferait
beatles de la charia
tu le vois dans le clip habillés en noir
comme les autres mais comme il a des
lunettes tu sais que c'est lui l'intello
et frais star de dèche c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
non
m
la france
on passe maintenant à notre terrienne du
samedi 20 heures
nathalie bard et
nathalie barrère bonsoir vous êtes né le
25 juillet 1965 à aunay-sur-odon dans le
calvados vos parents tient un magasin de
meubles votre père est menuisier votre
mère est à la caisse à l'adolescence
vous êtes une révolte et les études
c'est pas votre truc vous enchaîner
rapidement les petits boulots et vous
vous mariez vous avez deux enfants
vincent et thomas
après 17 ans de mariage vous divorcez et
le 21 juin 2001 c'est la fête de la
musique vos ados sont de sortie vos
copines ne sont pas dispo vous allez sur
internet vous discutez avec un dénommé
sylvain il a 27 ans et vous 36 voulait
prendre un verre ou danser un peu vous
quittez à 2 heures du matin mais huit
jours plus tard s'il va vous recontacte
bref nous donner à man et ils
s'installent chez vous tout va bien très
amoureuse bien sûr des conflits à fleurs
entre sylvain et vos fils mais bon comme
vous êtes dont la dans l'amour vous
arrondissait les angles à ce moment là
jusqu'au jour où un matin votre aîné
rentre d'une soirée en boîte et il
dispute éclate entre lui et sylvain est
là sylvain qui est très affecté
décide d'aller se reposer dans un
hôpital psychiatrique ça c'est là c'est
la fêlure dans le cristal ça c'est le
c'est la première fois où vous comprenez
quelque chose de pas tout à fait normal
c'est vrai que c'est un peu paniqué
j'arrivais pas à comprendre sa réaction
alors au retour il vous dit je veux un
enfant
et lave très heureuse évidemment vous
l'aimez vous faire un enfant vous dit
assez rapidement oui
mathis votre troisième enfant mais le 20
juin 2003
sylvain coupe lui même le cordon
ombilical
il se montre on peut le dire on perd
assez exceptionnel c'est vrai à ce
moment là c'était ça
hélas il ne tarde pas à retomber dans
ses travers
il devient ombrageux il devient taiseux
et ils vous interdit de parler à matisse
de vos deux autres enfants oui c'était
une source de conflit entre nous je lui
ai toujours tenu tête par rapport à ça
mais je limiter les conflits avec
monsieur journaux parce que ça devenait
ingérable vous l'appelez monsieur
jouanno joie nous monsieur jouanno ça
dépend dans quel état d'esprit suis
d'accord et puis à l'été 2004 en
fouillant sur internet vous découvrez
qu'il vous a trompé et là c'est le début
effectivement d'une descente aux enfers
qui n'est pas terminée malheureusement
un jour une dispute éclate entre vous et
une heure après vous trouvez jouanno
enfin moi je l'appelle simard est inerte
au près du lit de matisse vous lui
mettez des claques il répond pas il est
vivant a mais il est complètement inerte
vous appeler le samu
direction hôpital psychiatrique
diagnostic comportement limite proche de
la bipolarité
alors nouveau délire ils essaient de
vous convaincre d'avoir plusieurs femmes
oui ça j'ai pas du tout accepté il m'a
fait un gros chantage là dessus mais en
fait comme j'étais isolé à barentin tout
seul avec lui il pouvait faire ce qu'il
voulait il n'y avait pas de témoin début
2006 vous êtes épuisé vous êtes abonné à
vous peser 45 kg et vous annoncer à
silva que vous le quitter oui ça faisait
des mois qu'on vivait comme des
étrangers à la maison et il l'adresse
est plus la parole à battice on était en
danger tous les deux lors il accepte il
accepte votre décision mais il vous
demande de signer un document où vous
renoncez à votre pension alimentaire en
échange de quoi lui renonce à la garde
de matisse à
cette façon de se débarrasser de son
fils comme ça en monnayant et ça m'a
écoeuré j'ai signé le papier
et puis j'ai pleuré toute la nuit et le
lendemain je vais emmener matisse avec
moi dans le train
lors du divorce autre avocate vous dit
que ce document n'a aucune valeur
juridique
quand sylvain apprend vous avez parlé à
votre avocate il vous accuse de l'avoir
trahi et là commence entre vous et et
sylvain jouanneau une guerre sans merci
qui n'est toujours pas terminée évident
alors la fin de l'été 2008 vous
emménagez avec alain votre nouveau
compagnon tout va bien
le week-end mon mathis et chez son père
fait la fête avec alain après tout la
vie comme celle de beaucoup de couple
finira -
mais à l'automne 2010 matiz qui a 7 ans
revient d'un week-end chez son père et
il vous raconte qu'il a été obligé de
passer deux jours assis derrière un
bureau à recopier des lignes et tout ça
parce qu'il a fait pipi au lit ouais il
accomplit 6 en ligne
il a été ainsi pendant deux jours
seuls 16
je me suis dit que je leur donnerai plus
jamais bach le vendredi 2 septembre 2011
vous conduisez matisse à l'école il n'a
pas envie d'aller chez son père vous
leurs assurés mais le dimanche soir 18h
d'habitude il est à l'heure sauf que ce
dimanche là il est pas là et il est pas
là non plus à 19 à 20 à 21 22 il ramène
pas son fils
les policiers obtiennent des parents de
sylvain jouanneau le numéro
d'immatriculation de la voiture et son
camping car et le procureur autorise une
géolocalisation du portable de cils bon
apparemment utah bayonne apparemment
vous foncez à bayonne avec votre
compagnon la police est déjà en train de
travailler mais vous trouvez rien aucune
trace qui de matisse et de sylvain
jouanneau
la la géo localisation
indique un retour vers le nord de la
france
à ce moment là la gendarmerie la police
font des barrages dans l'orne mais j'ai
le lisa sion du téléphone montre qui
passe les barrages bon en fait est là
c'est absolument incroyable
sylvain jouanneau a envoyé son téléphone
par la poste donc c'est le camion qui a
passé les barrages dans l'orne
évidemment comprendre tout à semoy dans
sa lettre qui accompagne le portable
sylvain parle de complices sur et
puissant
quand on retrouve sa 206 on découvre un
ticket de carte bleue
concernant l'achat de trois livres
consacrés à l'enseignement du coran et
de l'islam aux enfants votre ex s'est
converti à l'islam qui sera prêt que je
sois parti il est allé au maroc
ainsi converti à l'islam et il a épousé
une et religieusement une marocain
le 9 décembre 2011 la joie nous est
arrêté à villeneuve-lès-avignon le
problème c'est que sylvain jouanneau
refuse de dire où et mathis oui c'est ça
la seule chose qu'il avoue c'est qu'il a
dit à matisse que vous êtes morte avec
votre compagnon dans un accident de
voiture
c'est terrible vous imaginez la violence
la violence des mots c'est
dans une lettre sylvain jouanneau
explique que mathis est en sécurité chez
des personnes de confiance en les
personnes de confiance avec messieurs
jouanno faut faire attention quoi vous
allez le voir en prison jouanno ça donne
rien n'en était rien alors là bon vous
faites des appels à témoins des
conférences de presse la police
interroge les pouces marocaine fait
appel à des médiums comme toute mère qui
recherche désespérément évidemment son
enfant
le 4 juin 2015 sylvain jouanneau et
condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
il affirme que mathis est convertie à
l'islam et qu'il a changé d'identité
mais il dit il confirme si je n'ai pas
tué voilà alors je voudrais montrer
maintenant une photo de matisse vieilli
par les services du
fbc ou fait drôle de voir votre enfant
avec quatre ans de plus j'imagine savez
on dit toujours un ça va tellement vite
mais là on se rend vraiment compte qu'il
ya quatre ans qui sont pas seuls
imaginons que mathis vous regarde vous
avez quelque chose à lui dire oui je
serai juste lui dire que je laime que je
fais tout pour le retrouver
et que je suis pas morte que je suis là
et voilà
excusez moi madame est une chose que je
comprends pas comment ça se fait que
sylvain jouanneau et en prison on lui
fait pas un sérum de vérité un détecteur
de mensonges à chaque fois on me dit
c'est interdit de le faire donc cet
homme sylvain jouanneau va passer vingt
ans en prison est et on l'obligera
jamais à parler
je comprends pas vraiment plu je
comprends pas dans tous les cas on est
tout coeur avec vous noté merci
voilà c'est un salut les terriens votre
taux du samedi soir avec florence
foresti
avec michel onfray
avec orelsan de la ville sont commencés
loi je vous laisse avec tomates ou et la
suite hugo re à venir le choc du top 14
clermont toulon salue l'état
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu